first off I want to say congrats for
getting the film made and you've taken
to several festivals is that right yeah
the last year it's been out at festivals
you know we started it rain dance in
London then it went on to play in Oaxaca
and a couple of their festivals around
the world and then you know ended up
playing it numerous like horror film
festivals in the US and yeah just
finished at one called fear fete in
Louisiana was our last festival so well
that's great yeah then you have this
distribution deal do you think that
filmmakers are aware of this problem
that happens though that when like the
films made you've had it screened and
then you kind of say now what do I do
with it do I try to go further with it
do I walk away is it's an interesting
thing you put so much time and energy
into something and then you reach this
crossroads where what do I do now did
you have sort of a moment with that did
you say where do I go with this sure you
know I mean he's always tough you know
your movie doesn't get in to Sundance on
these levels and you kind of feel like
oh well what you know what has good you
know what chance does movie have now to
kind of get out there and and you know I
think for us who you know sir we had
started to get some calls about digital
distribution and it still didn't feel
totally reeled at the same time until
kind of film buff came on and you know
had a good reputation and you know able
to see that they really get these movies
out there and it was like yeah the movie
really might have another life you know
I think yes I i I'm not sure what would
have happened to film up and have come
along whether we would have tried to go
with somebody else or whether you know
you end up having to do it on your own I
don't know it would have been a much
more difficult decision you know this
was even when we had
kind of we're starting to submit to
vessels this was it you know outside of
like becoming some huge hit the real
goal of the movie was to get you know
kind of a video-on-demand deal in the
movie could get out there and get seen
and in that that was kind of our well
you know that feels like a good goal for
the movie and it's still you know after
its kind of the festival run was going
it still didn't feel like I'm you know
anything I sheard and yeah there were
certainly moments where it was just like
well you know let this run out and then
on to the next one and you know this
this was what it is but yeah so that
that could have easily played out that
way did you actively seek out different
VOD deals or did you wait for people to
come to you um no we waited you know
then you know they started coming to us
and you know I think it was from the
horror festival circuit that they were
looking at titles and you know we had
people contact us to want to see
screeners and and then talked with them
so you know we hadn't hit that you know
path too much of sending out you know
looking for people to represent him so
we didn't have to get to that place
you